[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine amouk est acceptée dans
le clan demeure un des bois avec lui
elle se met au travail
puis elle est pauvre mais d'abord les
trouver
[Musique]
on
non
la bourse a ou la vie voilà qui est bien
est ce que je suis content bien tarco
les chercher le bonheur on en parle
beaucoup de ces nouveaux pauvres mais on
les voit pas souvent nouveau pauvre
petit robert nouveau port apparaissent
en général au cours d'une crise
économique
voir page 30 tout de même ça suffit le
dico à route pour de nouvelles aventures
mais avant ça suffit là bas encore à
notre endroit chic et encore on va
gagner tout de suite lui donne au dîner
j'ai l'impression que le morceau était
trop gros là je connais depuis longtemps
je connais leur budget c'est vraiment
des clients pour nous et on y va avant
pour l'instant on y va
[Musique]